hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute möchte ich meine fünf
absolut liebsten tomaten sollten
überhaupt mit euch teilen
es gibt ja so viele tomaten sollten da
draußen das ist oft super schwierig da
eine auswahl zu treffen
deswegen finde ich solche videos super
inspirierend ich werde euch heute fünf
sorten vorstellen die wir immer immer
immer wieder anbauen weil sie sich so
bewährt haben und weil sie so lecker
sind
[Musik]
ich habe noch ganz ganz viele andere
gerne tipps für euch parat also
abonniert den kanal und drückt auch die
glocke damit ihr benachrichtigt werden
sobald das nächste video erscheint jetzt
möchte ich euch viel spaß mit ihm
tomaten sollten alle sorten wie ich euch
hier vorstelle sind übrigens jahren fest
das heißt dass ihr immer wieder jedes
jahr sagt nun von euren eigenen tomaten
behalten können und dass im nächsten
jahr an bauen könnt und da gar nicht
mehr davon abhängig sein dass wir jedes
jahr neues saatgut kaufen willst hat ihr
euch fragt woran man erkennt ob saatgut
sachen fest ist da steht entweder auf
den tütchen mit drauf es gibt auch
züchter die nur sagen festes saatgut
familien ihr könnt uns auch über das
ausschlussverfahren feststellen wenn auf
dem sand tütchen hinter dem namen der
sorte einem f1 steht dann ist das hybrid
saatgut dass man ohne weiteres im
eigenen garten vermehren kann
vielleicht habt ihr ja eben schon
gespielt auf platz 15 haben wir diese
tomaten sollte die heißt value ich hoffe
ich spreche das richtig aus das ist eine
seite die ich aus einem ganz bestimmten
grund anbau und zwar weil sie in der
zweiten hälfte der saison also gegen
august bis oktober noch mal richtig gas
gibt und dann erst richtig ertrag
abwirft wenn die anderen sorten schon
anfangen zu schwächeln eine freiland
tomaten werden ja super schnell vom
braucht volle befallen und werfen dann
um die jahreszeit oft gar nicht mehr so
den ertrag ab und dann kommen sie ins
spiel und liegt richtig los deswegen war
ich diese sorte super gerne alles ist
eine kopf der tomate eine rote ich habe
leider dieses jahr glaube ich keine
bilder oder kaum bilder von diesen
sorgen die ich euch hier vorstelle
gemacht also muss ich erklären ich kann
halt auch nicht rausgehen und dann
tomaten ernten
weil weg dann erst januar haben amazon
macht ungefähr so große rote früchte
sicherlich zu der gäste sorgte im
gemüsegarten aber durchaus sehr lecker
und eben weil er so spät im jahr mal
richtig gas gibt ist das eine sorte die
das ganze andere tomaten sortiment
supermutter ergänzt platz nummer vier
belegt tatsächlich eine gelbe tomaten
sollte ich weiß nicht ob ich das auch so
geht aber ich finde gelbe tomatensaft
supercopa langweilig weil die einfach
nicht den säuregehalt haben denen rote
tomaten sollten haben deswegen bin ich
da immer etwas zögerlich aber diese
tomate die ich euch jetzt hier vorstelle
die hat absolut was auf dem kasten
obwohl sie gelb ist das ist die ananas
tomate ich hoffe es fokussiert ja die
ananas tomate ist eine wunderschöne
gelbe riesige tomaten sollte mit
rötlichen streifen oder markierungen
darauf die super super super lecker ist
und sehr ertragreich also eine absolute
empfehlung von mir für euch die ananas
tomate das einzige was ich da empfehlen
würde ist dass man wie geschützt an bord
am besten im gewächshaus weil sie sehr
wärme bedürftig ist generell sind alle
tomaten dankbar für ein dach über dem
kopf aber einige sind eben ein bisschen
freiland geeigneter als andere und die
ananas tomate gehört da er nicht dazu
bevor ich sie jetzt alle gegeben
tomatensorten schlecht rede verraten wir
durch auf ihren gelben orte kennt die
auch so lecker ist oder ob ihr auch eher
enttäuscht zeit von gelben sorten ich
freue mich immer wenn nämlich eines
besseren belehrt ich werde es auf jeden
fall schön doch ein paar mehr gelbe
sorten anzubauen also und da lassen wir
einen kommentar
wenn dir deine empfehlung für mich ab
platz drei belegt eine sorte die durch
das haus tomaten projekt vom
dreschflegel bekannt wurde
pflege ist eine züchtergemeinschaft von
züchtern die sich zur aufgabe gemacht
haben samen feste und alte gemüsesorten
zu erhalten und zu züchten ein ganz
tolles projekt und die haben eben ihre
kundinnen dazu aufgerufen
tomaten sollten die sich selber mir im
eigenen garten immer weiter familien die
so im handel da nicht gibt bei drei
schläge einzuschicken und da ist eine
sorte zu tage gekommen dienen sich
sibirisches birnchen eine ups soll jetzt
kennt das lesen eine sehr sehr süße
tomaten sollte sieg natürlich wirklich
aus wie ein kleines bienchen und kleines
boot ist bildchen macht die sehr viele
früchte super robust also dies auch
absolut freiland geeignet und sehr sehr
ertragreich die früchte schmecken sehr
sehr sehr lecker also das kann ich euch
sehr ans herz legen das sibirische
wirklich in einmal in eurem garten
auszuprobieren verraten wir mal unten in
den kommentaren was eure allerliebsten
tomatensorten sind so können wir da
unten in den kommentaren noch so ein
zweites tomaten ranking machen
ihr könnt dann den anderen auch immer
einen daumen hoch oder daumen runter
geben je nachdem ob ihr einverstanden
sei und so können wir uns noch viel mehr
inspirieren und gegenseitig tolle tipps
für tomaten sollten geben denn dann wird
spannend oder werfen auf platte nummer
zwei es ist eine sorte die ihr
wahrscheinlich alle kennt eine sehr
beliebte sorte und das absolut zu recht
es ist die black cherry cocktailtomaten
eine super leckere brote tomate die so
eine lila über zu kann also nicht ist
nicht schwarz auf wenn sie black cherry
hast eine sehr sehr sehr sehr sehr
leckere tomate und dass es vor allem mit
abstand die ertragreichste sorte gewesen
in unserem garten in den letzten drei
jahren
wir haben die auch schon im freiland
sehr erfolgreich angebaut auch wenn die
oft nicht als freiheit
gelistet wird finde ich sie doch
wirklich sehr bewusst und super toll
also die cocktailtomaten black cherry
eine absolute empfehlung von uns
wirklich also platz eins übertrifft die
wirklich nur minimal im geschmack das
war ein ganz klares revier und rolle ob
der platz nummer eins da landet eine
tomaten sollte die auf super lecker ist
es ist mit abstand die leckerste sorte
liebe je angebaut haben es ist eine
super ertragreiche sorte auf eine
cocktail tomaten
es ist die zocker traube ich hab jetzt
klein sagt wer dennoch selber
gesammeltes saatgut dann ist eine super
super super leckere tomaten sollte die
schmeckt genauso wie sie sich anhört zur
traube
die macht ungefähr so große rote früchte
und zwar massenhaft die wächst auch im
freiland einigermaßen ich würde sie
schon eher geschützt anbauen und die
schmeckt mit abstand am allerbesten
deswegen ist sie auf platz eins meine
ganze familie ist so begeistert von
dieser tomaten sollte dass die
mittlerweile fast jeder der einen garten
hat bei uns an bord also eine absolute
empfehlung die zucker treiber probiert
die auf jeden fall mal aus ansonsten
kannst du dir hier falls du noch keinen
pflanzplan erstellt hast meine
videoreihe anschauen dann gehen wir das
schritt für schritt zusammen durch
dauernden des abends spannendes video
ich hoffe wir sehen uns gleich wieder
biss dann schafft